الحادي عشر من نوفمبر المقبل يوافق يوم
العزاب او دبل اليفن هو اكبر يوم للتسوق
عبر الانترنت في العالم مبيعته اعلى من
ايام التسوق امازون برايم وبلاك فرايدي
مجتمعه شركات علي بابا الصينيه هي
المسؤوله عن الحصه الاكبر مبيعات التجاره
الالكترونيه في اليوم منذ اطلاقها
المهرجان في عام 2009 في العام الماضي
حققت علي بابا مع المنصه المنافسه
239 مليار دولار في يوم العزه ورغم ان
نسخه العام تشهد ظروفا اصعب مع اهتزاز ثقه
المستهلك الصيني بسبب قيود قرون المشدده
وتحضيرات التضخم الا ان التوقعات تشير ان
الاستهلاك لن يتاثر كثيرا يوم العذاب
بيمتدوا لاسابيه قبل يوم الحدث نفسه
لاختبار اتجاهات العملاء ومعرفه ما يجذبهم
قبل الحادي عشر وحاليا يكتشفوا طريقه
تدريجيا خارج حدود الصين الى مناطق كثيره
حول العالم في اتفضل وحتى في امريكا
[موسيقى]
لماذا يوم العزات تحديدا يحقق كل هذه
المبيعات المهوله المتحدث عن سايكولوجيه
اليوم في يوم العزابي يتم خلق ظاهره شو
يعني ظاهره لما يكون في عندك ظاهره لنفترض
مثلا مسلسل
اه كثير اوف ماسنجر اوت الخوف من تفويت
الفرصه الكل يتكلم وانا مش عارفه شو هذا
المسلسل اضطريت ادخل بس لما يكون المسلسل
او يكون الشيء على مدى فتره طويله ما تخلق
ارجنسي مش مضطره الا اليوم اشوف الحلقه بس
لما يكون على 24 ساعه فقط هذا يخلق شيء
يسمى اورجنسي ضروري الان الان الان لازم
انتمي الى هذا الحدث او هذه الظاهره فحتى
الشخص اللي ما يريد يتساق او ما عنده فضول
لتسويق هو يريد ينتمي الى هذه الظاهره اذا
كانت الظاهره هي اهداء النفس هو ليش اسمه
يوم العزابيه كلها
عن اهداء نفسه حب النفس لانه اصلا اجت
يعني مثلا مقابله الفالنتاين هناك
الفالنتاين عيد الحب اليوم عيدنا عيد
الاعزاء بالاشخاص السنجلز همم اليوم هذه
الظاهره يعني خلق الظاهره اورجنت الان
لازم تحدث لازم اتسوق الان وهذا اهداء
لنفسي فهذا ادى الى الباقيلاتي مثل ما
شفنا 139 مليار دولار هذا اقتصاد للمغرب
تقريبا
ولم تلاقي المغرب اقتصادها 100 وش 40 وشيء
مليار دولار فتخيلي انت هذه المبيعات كلها
تمت خلال 24 ساعه
[موسيقى]